that is one of the most iconic scenes in
movie history Charlton Heston winning
the chariot race in the 1959 movie Ben
Hur and with me right now is the man
taking over the reigns for Charlton
Heston and the reimagining of the movie
okay
Jack Houston no pressure there right no
no pressure at all it's it's an
incredible honor to be stepping into
child master sandals we first saw you at
work we were first on the set in Italy
and now you're bringing us the world's
mirror off the first themes which I'm
very excited about and what can we
expect well this is the exclusive first
look of the movie
no one's seen anything before so we're
really excited to show everyone this
this is a movie that has such a
beautiful message of - grand epic what
is your name calling for blood crucified
it's about the love of two brothers who
fall out and it's a misunderstanding
there that's Judah ben-hur they see as a
slave and his family off to the cross
and it's this incredible story of
redemption if your brother was to cry at
home to beat him and you're defeated
then you will have your vengeance should
have stayed away you should have killed
me I will for the territory how real was
it because everybody is used to
everything being so digital was it
really that real everything is
incredibly offensive like we really did
everything in that when you see me and
Toby we're four horses going round that
track matter and nothing prepares you
for that it's um you're making me sweat
right now I think I'm serious it's um I
think the first day I always said that
you you you you're their'n and the power
you realize why you can cause the story
it's still refer to as horse power
it looks amazing and I tell you invite
two of the most amazing producers as
well Marvin and Roma Downey of the
greatest we just adore them I love them
I know they love you thank you so much
thank you